so you had like you know you had the
thing with the Logan Paul thing that
happened right in hinds like and you
know he kind of called you out and then
you kind of burned him a little bit but
um is that safe to say yeah I mean I
think I I think I probably started it I
I did well but I mean I just meant it as
like a he was like last blog it's
important and I wrote no it's not no
it's not yeah but I mean like that's
because like first of all it's not your
last blog yeah second of all it's not
important yeah and you know that yeah
and do you think did you know that was
gonna go as crazy is it no no I didn't
think you'd respond yeah he responded
his what bait that's what really when he
responded oh also it's like when he
respond it was when he responded it was
like is that word responded I'm getting
off yes he was fun he responded and he
was like uh I know and I looked at it
and I was like oh damn I was like I
almost immediately kind of felt bad for
him yeah because I was like this is
gonna be horrible for you right because
this is what I do
yes that's true and also everybody
already doesn't like you right so it's
easy for me hmm and I was like oh I have
the as soon as I saw it I was like I got
the best thing to say yeah this is what
you'd say and I thought about it and I'm
like this is the thing to say yeah and I
posted it I went to bed yeah and I woke
up and it was like I was on The Tonight
Show in 1985 ha ha it was like people
were like hey man what's up drunk
driving walking down the street doesn't
Jesus Christ real Arius yeah dude was
hilarious it was hilarious
I'll go to the gym people like hey man
[ __ ] take that guy down it was some
guy at the gym yeah yeah and there it is
kita there and I did and I'm having fun
you know I'm sure yes I always say
people aren't what they say they're who
they are and I think we've lost sight of
that in this 100 and age it's like
somebody says something or like I'll
[ __ ] that guy and you know this kid did
that thing he did a dumb thing I'm gonna
take the benefit of the doubt I'm
have I'm gonna say he knows that that
was dumb yeah I'm sure if you were to do
it he wouldn't do it again and not
because of it would ruin his business
but because he knows that that's a
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] thing to do right
I'm sure he's a good guy I'm sure he's a
good kid I'm gonna take the benefit of
the doubt I'm sure he's a good guy
I probably when I hung out with if I
were to ever hang out with him I
probably be like this guys are [ __ ]
annoying his [ __ ] yeah but like I would
just playfully be like yeah you [ __ ]
idiot what the hell are you so stupid
don't do that [ __ ] and you'd probably
laugh it off and we'd be probably like
oh you're [ __ ] you're stupid too cuz
of this and maybe we get along yeah I
like that [ __ ] but um then he kept going
and and in my mind he's just having fun
but I don't know maybe not maybe he is
actually angry at me
cuz I'm just having fun - it's just fun
it's just funny like what are you doing
don't do this - first of all don't do
this don't do this - a comedian right
period cuz this is their job right and
you're an adult yes there's that - but
also don't do it to me yeah I'm
definitely gonna write back right I'm
not Jerry Seinfeld right who's just like
oh you [ __ ] wrote that about me uh who
who wants to waste time on that guy
right I am petty [ __ ] yeah
I'm gonna do it the [ __ ]
was there any aftermath that people
didn't see like was there communication
after were like he reached out or you
reached out or you know the dude or any
publicist reach out that know what's
what's today
no there's nothing no no no just
everybody talked about it yeah I gave
just it was just wild I got a lot of
followers off of it which is I didn't
really expect it was insane I mean it
was I guess he never had much did ya it
got more favorites and retweets than any
Donald Trump yeah it got nice em yeah
Wow
yeah what yeah wild yeah it was it was
huge it was huge
it was huge as a matter of fact it
happened the same week that that Kanye
thing happened where he said slavery was
a choice mhm I wonder if that if that
didn't happen how big it would have been
hmm because that should all obviously
took over the whole world
yeah like yeah it was so crazy how big
it went yeah the
know that something could get that big
like did it even believe had to have
blown your mind a little bit it was
funny yeah I was like what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah I guess that's a lot Wow
six hundred sixty-four thousand likes
hundred forty nine thousand that's Guam
let's everybody in Guam few times over
but everybody in Guam with the retweets
right yeah 160 mm oh yeah yeah yeah with
the retweets yeah but yeah what if
everyone who read tweeted it was just
everyone in Guam yeah that was just like
a [ __ ] wow you know it's crazy as my
sister can't even read but what does it
have to do with us right now hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one